foreign
you have a story where you broke your
wrist when you were on the verge of
you're playing Arena Football League yep
and you're with dreams of aspirations of
going NFL yep and you broke your wrist
ended up being a more serious break
and while you're at home like any
athlete who's been laid up
there's that
little bit of doubt and a little bit of
I could I'll be back and then that
little bit of like people like hey are
you still playing yeah you're like no
man I'm hurt but I'm cut like there's
all that right if you're and athlete you
get that world
then your dad gets in yeah a
life-altering car wreck yep okay big
brain injury yeah
here's where my head went so I spent
most of my career showing up to that
situation either to tell Lewis hey this
just happened or with the family right
yeah so when I'm reading this part in
your book
here's here's with the hook into my
heart tell me about being a son a strong
powerful pro football player yeah right
right which puts you in the top one
percent of the top one percent
and
there's this moment we all have when our
dads are suddenly
powerless yeah
take me back there as this you can't go
overseas so he was on vacation he was in
New Zealand and I've just broken three
ribs the next day in a football game and
so I couldn't travel for I can't travel
yeah and then he comes back and there's
that shape-shifting moment where I can
do all things I can lift I can do the
225 bench workout I can do all that
I can't fix that no man it was
devastating take me back there it was
sad man I remember him coming off the
plan we were at the airport waiting for
him to come back
and it's kind of like being helped to
walk you can't fully really walk by
himself but he's kind of hobbling off of
like the airport coming towards the exit
and I give him a hug and it was the
moment I was like oh man
he's a completely different person like
mentally emotional well like mentally
emotionally psychologically personality
wise he's different
and I was like okay
well he's gonna come back you know he's
gonna get better
and I remember just year after year it
was struggle man he didn't he he got a
little bit better
but his personality almost completely
changed not because he wanted it to but
the brain trauma was so intense that it
just messed up the chemicals in her
brain and he just
so it was very challenging every time
I'd go and see him we'd say
what's your name oh man uh oh that's
right Lewis yeah
um used to play sports right what sport
did you play again where did you go to
school
now here's a man who went to almost
every one of my games he was on the
field taking photos was like championing
me like celebrating me all the time in
athletics he was there he showed up
for him to not even know that I used to
play sports and have to constantly for
17 years he used to be like
where'd you go to school again so I have
to show him photos and remind him he
goes oh yeah okay yeah you play football
right and oh yeah but it was just man
it's just hard when you're used to
seeing something with someone you know
your father and he's not that anymore
it's like he almost it's like he died
that's right emotionally but he uh
physically was there I've had someone
describe maybe one of the most
heart-wrenching heartbreaking
conversation I've ever had was someone
explaining what it's like when a parent
has Alzheimer's Alzheimer's yeah man
like so hard and to have your mom look
at you and not know your name it was
it's disorienting it's really and it's
it's traumatizing yeah it's it affected
all I have three siblings and I'm the
youngest of four so it's
it impacted all of us in different ways
and we all experienced pain in other in
certain ways
and at the same time
it
it helped Define me into wanting to make
an impact and serve people in a bigger
way so I wish it didn't happen but at
the same time
I eventually after about four or five
years accepted it because it was going
to drive me mad because I kept trying to
change it half horses like what can I do
to make this what doctor can I call who
can I get him on our program and we just
need to teach him more we need you know
trying to force something and realizing
like
he's got a different purpose he can't
work he can't cook he can't drive he
can't do anything he sits there and he
doesn't want to have a drive anymore he
was a big loving happy driven smart man
and the Brain just so affected that it's
different now it's different and
accepting him where he's at was one of
the hardest things accepting your father
not recognize you accepting him and just
loving him with his new purpose for this
season
and I never was able to really grieve
though because he was still alive yeah
he passed a year ago okay I'm sorry to
hear that thank you yeah thank you and
it was it was like the first time I
could grieve after 17 years of his first
death his emotional and mental deaths
but last year he physically passed
and I finally allowed myself to come I
like accepted it before
but it was almost like I could finally
have a have a different relationship
with him now where I couldn't have them
for 17 years now I feel like I have a
true spiritual relationship with him
right
and it's um
it's been part of the healing grieving
process you know as I don't think I've
fully grieved while he was alive even
though he was here right yeah so that
was uh he was traumatic man but um you
know we all have different traumas Big T
Little T as you know
and we all have something to face yeah
and that was just the thing that I
needed to face and you talked about how
you know a lot of people run away from
there I think I can remember the story
of death or story or something but it
was like have a culture we've running
away from it hiding it not talking about
it right Outsource at all right yeah I
love that chapter about that because
you know some of the happiest people in
the world think about their death
multiple times a day that's right I
think it's the country of Bhutan that
that practices five times a day thinking
about their that's right that's right
yeah yeah yeah and they focus I don't
think they're the very stages of them in
the in the grave but they're just like
okay and there's an app uh that a friend
told me about called we croak and it's
an app that five times a day it tells
you you're gonna die
and and the whole point of it and then
it has like an inspiring quote so make
sure you like appreciate what you have
right now so being gratitude so kiss the
person you love it's a reminder of like
life is now